Daniel has been called a murderer by
some a vigilante by others many claim
that he he acted based on race what do
you say to those people none of that is
based on the facts
um
as to as to race it's simply not the
motivation for Danny he is the one that
put himself in danger to save who all
the people on that train that black
people brown people white people it
didn't matter to Danny Danny put his
life at risk to save all those people
has nothing to do with race hey Sean
Hannity here hey click here to subscribe
to Fox News YouTube page and catch our
hottest interviews and most compelling
analysis you will not get it anywhere
else